[Música]
nosotros vamos ahora en directo a
Estados Unidos vamos a conectar con
nuestro corresponsal en Washington
Cristóbal Vázquez para abordar dos temas
que marcan la actualidad estadounidense
Cristóbal buenas noches para usted se
acerca la fecha límite del 1 de junio y
avanza la incertidumbre sobre Qué puede
pasar si demócratas y republicanos no
acuerdan una ampliación del techo de la
deuda Y ante esta situación parte de la
bancada demócrata Pide al presidente Joe
biden que use la enmienda 14 le pregunto
de qué se trata este recurso Y qué
escenario se abren
los que le están pidiendo los demócratas
en el senado a través de una carta es
precisamente que aplique que
empiece con aplicar esta enmienda 14 que
pues en su momento le decía los estados
del Sur que perdieron la guerra civil
que tenían que responder a las deudas
financieras que implicó haber el luchado
contra los estados del norte y entonces
lo que esto llevaría sería que el
presidente tuviera entonces la potestad
bajo esta premisa de proteger las deudas
y las obligaciones financieras de
Estados Unidos de pedirle al
departamento del tesoro completamente
allá que pues simplemente emita más
bonos de deuda para financiar el
gobierno sin embargo el propio
presidente ha dicho que esto sería un
camino bastante tedioso bastante largo
porque implicaría mucho litigio ya
incluso grupos republicanos están
preparando demandas en caso de
decida ir adelante con esta petición de
los demócratas de de usar enmienda 14
para poder seguir financiando el
gobierno en caso de que no se llegue a
este acuerdo de el límite de la deuda
que entre otros efectos económicos pues
obviamente tendría efectos económicos en
la calificación crediticia del país y
Por ende en el costo de poder endeudarse
bueno Cristóbal pendientes de esta
petición de si se acaba usando esta
enmienda o no pero cambiemos de tema
porque hoy el fallo a favor de Twitter
Google y Facebook en una sentencia que
absuelve a las grandes compañías de
comunicaciones de responsabilidades Por
cierto contenido que se difunde en sus
plataformas Pues fue emitida no por el
tribunal supremo de qué se trata este
fallo exactamente Y qué precedentes
puede sentar
pues estas familias que demandaban a
YouTube de Google y a Twitter entre
otras de fomentar contenido que llevaba
a que estos grupos terroristas como Isis
no solamente radicalizara a jóvenes sino
que también reclutar a jóvenes y estas
familias querían hacer ver como a través
de estas plataformas a través de los
algoritmos que estas plataformas manejan
pues tienen riesgo tenían
responsabilidad de esta radicalización
este reclutamiento de personas que
terminaron convirtiendo estos actos
terroristas en los que murieron los
seres queridos de estas personas pero
Clarence tomas y los nueve magistrados
de la Corte Suprema de Justicia la
máxima instancia judicial en Estados
Unidos simplemente dijeron que no que no
había suficiente evidencia para vincular
a estas empresas y para
responsabilizarlas de que su accionar
tuviera alguna influencia en los actos
terroristas de organizaciones como Isis
y es una victoria porque pues estas
empresas como el Google como YouTube que
invierten millones de dólares en Lobby
en cabildeo para protegerse en el
congreso pues protegen estas secciones
esta famosa y conocida sección 230 en
Estados Unidos que pues simplemente los
exonera de responsabilidad de la
información que sus usuarios publican en
estas plataformas sociales